hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think here and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the movie two
guns two guns uh starring denzel
washington and mark wahlberg the new
bromance has been has been made yeah
it's based off of a comic book yeah from
boom studios you know the kind of
smaller independent companies yeah
i didn't know much about i think the
book came out like in 2008 i heard i
didn't i'd never read it so i didn't
know much about it i think most people
don't know that it was based on a comic
book no they probably think it's a
regular action movie yeah yeah um i
thought it was all right i mean it was
it was solid yeah you know had some
some entertaining moments um
it was a little long i think yeah it was
a bit long for for what it was right
story wise it was yeah the story didn't
really didn't really care about the
story it was kind of convoluted yeah uh
they made things try and be all
complicated and complex but i mean the
best part of the movie was really just
kind of the interactions between uh mark
wahlberg and denzel washington i mean
they definitely made the film uh their
camaraderie like they're they have great
on-screen chemistry the thing is i was
watching this movie i was like man i
kind of like to see another one maybe
with a better story maybe tighten it up
a little bit doesn't need to be this
movie was almost two hours it could have
been a little less than two hours maybe
an hour and a half but i like them as
like a duo i think they make a good team
i wouldn't mind seeing a sequel if it
was maybe a little bit better story but
they tried to give denzel some like deep
moments where he's like contemplating
like trying to do like is like you know
oscar performance worthy stuff like
denzel i don't need to go that far with
this move it's just a straight up action
movie like all you need to do but
otherwise i thought it was good i
thought the director did a good job with
it yeah it's this icelandic director
balthasar right uh he did contraband
which i didn't see that mark wahlberg
was in so
um yeah i just thought it was solid it's
definitely some lulls there yeah that's
the thing i think they could have
probably rained in about you know 15 20
minutes less maybe yeah but i was gonna
say i do like that a great supporting
cast you know bill paxton
james almost james almost you know
then james barr cyclops was in it paula
patton you get to see her top lesson i
was surprised to see that like when i
saw it i was like oh that's a body
double just because i haven't seen her
like i was like oh no that's just her
she's she's showing i was like all right
paula you know all right yeah you know i
guess her husband's robin thinks into
that music you know so she's got to show
something who knows but uh it's good
though it was good i
again like i said it wasn't great but it
was a good summer action movie it is
what it is it's kind of what you see in
the previews what you get yeah i don't
know why though that you know they tried
to do this thing or the director tried
to do this kind of quentin tarantino
change around play around with the time
you know showed like this and it wasn't
you can do that i've seen some really
good movies do that but there was no it
wasn't necessary for this movie to do
yeah like to start in the middle and you
know it didn't lead up to anything it
didn't help you know when you watch
something like pulp fiction there's a
reason why it's rearranged
you know
the how the stories and the time
sequences are all real when you watch
the preview i mean they pretty much if
you've seen a trailer for it you've
pretty much seen most of the movie i
mean especially the part when you find i
mean it's in the preview it's not a
spoiler like you know and you know
denzel and mark find out that they're
both you know working for different
agencies like that's in the trailer over
and over again and i was watching moving
like man this is taking a while to get
to that part of my mind 45 minutes i
know and i'm like man i already know the
story i already know that that's going
to happen like there's no spoil there's
no like surprise shock value so i think
the movie just took too long to get
going but every time wahlberg and denzel
were on the screen i thought it was
great i thought the movie was strong
they're like i said their chemistry was
great but beyond that everything else
outside of that was kind of boring i
thought yeah yeah i mean you know the
action is pretty pretty standard stuff
the story's you know pretty
yeah pretty pretty generic
you know
you know double cross triple cross
you know these people are corrupt these
people corrupt et cetera et cetera
there's nothing you didn't see coming in
you know it kind of comes your typical
like bromance you know
i mean we've seen it lethal weapon you
know it's even funny it's like a black
hop and a white guy i mean it's good
it's just it's nothing that you haven't
seen before i wouldn't say rush out in
the theater to see this it's probably a
better rental it's worth a rent yeah i
would say when it comes on a red box or
netflix definitely check it out it's
worth it yeah yeah i don't know if you
have to see it in the theater but no
overall what would you give it
i'll give it a i give it a b minus you
know otherwise it's not awful but it's
just not it's just really average so
i'll give it a b my it's passable let's
give it a b minus i'm kind of like b
minus slash c plus okay yeah yeah during
certain parts of the movie i was like oh
yeah this is entertaining the other
person i'm like oh i'm falling asleep
right now like
so it wasn't you know yeah yeah so all
right uh if you saw the movie you can uh
post your comments below on the website
thinkhero.com we're gonna check us out
on youtube at our channel think hero pro
and we're also on twitter uh mine is at
think hero i'm at griffinde and we also
have a facebook page that's uh
facebook.comthinkgirlfans and also make
sure to subscribe to our youtube channel
uh thinkheropro yeah all right thanks
you